en 53 le général eisenhower le vainqueur
d'hitler avait remporté l'élection
présidentielle aux etats-unis
aujourd'hui un autre général colin
powell le vainqueur de saddam hussein
est en tête des sondages à 13 mois du
scrutin âgé de 58 ans le général powell
a quitté l'armée il y a deux ans après y
avoir fait toute sa carrière il est ce
soir notre invité de passage en france
pour la promotion de son autobiographie
un livre qui bat actuellement des
records de ventes aux etats unis enfant
du bronx paru chez odile jacob la saga
d'un fils d'immigré jamaïcain parvenu au
sommet de la hiérarchie militaire
pigassou ce fils d'immigrants jamaïcain
n'était pas véritablement disposé à
devenir militaire dans son quartier de
banana kelly dans le sud du bronx à new
york là le futur était plus que limité
c'est à l'université à 17 ans qu'il
découvre que l'armée est peut-être sa
chance lorsqu'il revêt l'uniforme pour
la première fois ils pensent qu'il a
découvert là quelque chose qui lui plaît
et qu'il fait bien à cette époque
l'armée était souvent la seule espérance
de promotion pour les noirs au vietnam
il sera platoon leader chef d'une
trentaine d'hommes sous la présidence de
ronald reagan il est conseiller à la
sécurité ce sont donc les républicains
qui les premiers lui font confiance avec
george bush toujours républicain il
devient chef d'état major ce sera son
rôle pendant la guerre du golfe c'est là
que le monde le découvrira en compagnie
du général schwarzkopf son étoile brille
le président clinton reconduire à kalin
powell dans ses fonctions il prendra sa
retraite de général en 1993 cet homme à
la carrière transparente a pourtant une
ambiguïté à la veille une éventuelle
candidature à la présidence et il
répondit qu un ou démocrate
colin powell bonsoir pour la première
fois donc un noir est aux portes de la
maison blanche que l'on dit est ce que
vous allez annoncer ou non votre
candidature début novembre comme promis
c'est ce que je vais examiner dans les
deux semaines à venir
j'examine les options politiques
la façon dont je vois et dont le peuple
américain me vois et puis il faudra je
prenne une décision
pour savoir si je fais la transition de
soldats un politicien il faut aussi que
je pense à ma famille alors je ne vous
ferai pas dire ce soir ce que vous
refuser obstinément de dire à mes
confrères américains bien sûr simplement
je voudrais vous demander est ce que
vous vous sentez capable de la passion
nécessaire pour passer quatre ans à la
maison blanche que vous connaissez très
bien
c'est vraiment la question
gv enthousiaste j'avais d'entre eux chez
ace mais la passion d'être un soldat et
maintenant je m'examiner jo
américain pour voir si l'enthousiasmé
cette passion peuvent déjà avant
d'adhérer maison blanche me permettre
d'être un politicien en campagne je n'ai
jamais fait soi qui s'inscrit pour
personne votre femme est pas très très
favorable elle a passé quatre ans la
maison blanche
ma femme fait certainement des réserves
en ce qui concerne la perte de vies
privées et non seulement la campagne
mais au fil des quatre ans à la maison
blanche elle est servi dans l'armée
pendant trente trois ans et elle n'est
pas sûre
comme cela qu'elle veut passer les
autres années de sa vie mais je crois
que si j'ai une chose qui est importante
pour le pays elle le fera son
enthousiasme et 10 ont contrôlé pour
l'instant est-ce que la couleur de votre
peau est déterminante dans les états
unis de 1996 politiquement
qui est tout à fait remarquable
au sujet de la tension que l'on me donne
c'est que c'est un signe de progrès qu
aux etats-unis pour la première fois
histoire on pense à une personne de
couleur pour devenir président
et donc quand on examine des choses
comme le procès au 10 ème sony
et les relations raciales aux états unis
l'amérique a fait de tels progrès que
maintenant les choses deviennent tel
qu'il est possible même de penser à une
personne de couleur pour être président
mais vous avez approuvé l'acquittement
de jill simpson
décision de la cour était la décision de
12 hommes et femmes qui ont pendant neuf
mois écoutez ce qu'il y avait à entendre
et ils ont décidé qu'il n'était pas
un coupable et nous devons accepter ce
jugement
ces gens on avait la responsabilité de
prendre la décision ils ont pris leur
décision et je n'accepte ultime question
d'un mot ou est-ce que vous êtes
favorable ou non à l'envoi de nombreux
gi's en bosnie dans l'ex yougoslavie
vous qui connaissez très bien la
géopolitique la situation militaire
oui absolument ça fait partie de notre
effort pour maintenir la paix merci
infiniment colin powell la davar était
notre invité ce soir est donc je
rappelle que vous annoncerez en principe
début novembre aux états unis si vous
êtes ou non candidat à la maison blanche
pour le scrutin de novembre prochain
novembre 96 merci encore
[Musique]